So really we're on the brink,
I think, of a transformation
in the way science is done.
Not only tackling the
problem of climate change
and trying to find solutions,
but also actually trying to
understand the system itself.
So some of the technological advances
that we might be able to use
to combat climate change
involve the ability
to generate energy
in sustainable ways.
The question today is can we make
solar panels or other materials
that are capable of generating
energy in useful ways?
In the past, scientists and engineers
have developed new materials,
but in rather a haphazard way.
Thomas Edison created the lightbulb
but he developed
the original filament
by testing thousands of materials to
find eventually the one that worked.
Today we can use machine
learning and artificial intelligence
in our search for new materials.
The reason that we can
do it better in the computer
is that the computer allows
millions of potential solutions
to be searched in ways that
you couldn't do in the lab.
The reason that AI is important in
the development of our understanding
of the Earth's system is that
we're getting more and more data
about the Earth as time goes on.
So today we collect satellite data,
remote sensing observations
allow us now
to look at the patterns
of landslides.
As climate is changing,
as weather patterns change,
is the land being more destabilised
by excess water?
Or are the erosion patterns
in the mountains
changing as climate changes?
Extreme weather events
as a result of climate change
do appear to be on the increase.
But there's another aspect of this -
cities are getting bigger,
areas that have always been
vulnerable to natural hazards.
With so many people
potentially at risk,
it becomes important to understand
the system very quickly.
Examples include
understanding the ways in which
to respond to a situation.
Where to send the first responders.
Which hospital is put on high alert.
Where to send relief supplies,
who needs tents.
So all of these sorts of
disaster relief processes
depend upon information.
And we know, as we travel
around congested cities,
that we spend a lot
of time sitting in traffic,
burning energy, getting nowhere.
Autonomous vehicles provide routes
to making transport systems
more effective, more efficient,
so that you don't have these waves
of static traffic on a motorway.
That everything is moving
at the right speed
and gets from one place
to another in the most effective way,
the most efficient way.
That's not something that,
as individuals,
we're very good at
planning for ourselves.
So if we want to reduce, recycle,
reuse, can AI help us?
Well maybe. But it depends
upon our motivation.
AI is a tool, it's not a master,
and so our responses ultimately
will depend upon our own
personal motivations,
and those of the society
that we're part of.
But AI and machine learning can
help us move in the right direction.